okay i'm lois
and i'm charlie
and we have been told and we believe
that we have
the largest private collection
of insects in the world yeah
the story of how we met was uh
interesting enough
i was a teaching assistant at
the university of arizona and lois was a
student in the class that i was teaching
we've been married for almost 55 years
he's got a million stories about insects
all of which i've heard and all of which
i can fill in sentences
and we've traveled extensively i've been
to all the continents and 70 countries
collecting
it fills us with pleasure to get into
the field and collect to spend the time
in the field together
oh you need to look at the antennae on
one of these it looks like a clown shoe
well i study weevils and the weevils are
the largest family of living organisms
these are plant hoppers and i think
their noses are cute i collect plant
hoppers which are insects that feed on
the juices of plants the phloem or the
xylem with piercing sucking mouth parts
with piercing sucking mouth parts
oh yeah this is interesting when when we
get some insects in
they're just dead
of course we have to mount them so we
have to pin them or
point them
and then we label them
the glue was not stiff enough and he's
fallen off his point
then after i do that then i sort him to
genus
each of these units trays holds 55
specimens on average
and we have at least a million weevils
and a quarter of a million plant hours
okay here you come charlotte
we are donating the collection to
arizona state university and there will
be research done on it which is what we
wanted to have happen
when we were entomologists at the
university we worked 14 hours a day
seven days a week now we're down to
eight to ten hours a day seven days a
week
it's a lot of work but we both loved
what we were doing and it was sharing
that was part of our life yeah which one
do you think is the prettiest these two
i don't like that one lois has often
taken note the fact that a very large
number of entomologists are divorced
what i recommend is if you're going to
be a taxonomist a systematist collect
insects
you get a spouse that is another
entomologist